[Música]
nada se crea nada se pierde todo se
transforma esta célebre máxima que ha
recorrido los siglos es hoy en día el
lema del áfrica global recycling creada
en lomé togo en 2013 se volvió la
primera empresa de clasificación y
revalorización de los residuos en áfrica
occidental
estoy convencido y lo repito todo el día
que la palanca de desarrollo más
importante de áfrica aún desconocida
sigue siendo el residuo de uno de los
grandes desafíos por ejemplo son los que
le dicen lo que hace es maravilloso pero
finalmente no le aportan solución la
estructuración de la rama residuos en
áfrica provee miles y miles de empleos
la moto la moda puede encontrar material
en esto tanto en el plástico como en el
textil o el papel para su animar a la
mujer al hombre a la fao y ello gracias
a los residuos es fabuloso no no
hoy este experto en economía verde
recibe modelos para una sesión de fotos
en medio de desperdicios valorizados de
toda índole una mañana de
sensibilización imaginada por el
diseñador ya que el logo fundador del
film o 228 el festival internacional de
la moda en tu colección
antes de preparar una colección hay
muchos residuos que generamos mucho es
decir que quedan telas hilos y todo eso
entonces este año nos dijimos que para
el film 228
la octava edición debíamos obrar en este
servidor para sensibilizar a los
diseñadores y hacerles entender que para
proteger mejor el medio ambiente debemos
gestionar mejor dichos residuos nada se
crea nada se pierde todo se transforma y
se cree real necesita más fam para
organizar un festival de moda en periodo
de kobe es un desafío a pesar de una
disminución en el presupuesto 120
invitados en lugar de los 2 mil 500
habituales de los diseñadores y las
modelos que ya no pueden viajar luego
sigue con un optimismo inquebrantable
desde que la pandemia llegó todo está
detenido los diseñadores de moda ya no
trabajan están desempleados
prácticamente el kama pero de todas
formas es posible darse gusto a sí mismo
y no se viste bien en toma fotos trabaja
con el fin de motivar a los diseñadores
que no paran de diseñar a pesar de la
pandemia
[Música]
así venda mucho menos desde el inicio de
los confinamientos la diseñadora de moda
beninesa togolesa de origen nigeriano
que hizo wallace no quiere lamentarse
su colección es una oda a las abejas a
las aves a la vida a la esperanza de
nacimiento y por supuesto al reciclaje
hice mucho con el bordado pero con
caídas de telas recicladas para crear
dibujos de disney son muchos bordados
con alambres metálicos y todo esto son
wax de las holandesas wax holandeses
africanos bordados en una tela de un
solo color pero al mismo tiempo son las
caídas de las telas los diferentes tipos
que hacen el trabajo que fue un total
hay
él también recicla pero material de
cocina miguel tough ojos um viene del
vecino ven y me llamo su marca rico o
nada porque no somos nada solo
enriquecidos de nosotros mismos le tomó
18 meses tejer su colección en regreso a
lo esencial conforme a los métodos
tradicionales el primer vestido es de
1.200 piezas de felpa de hierro
es muy cómodo y lo puedo llevar a todas
partes
esta colección revisitada fue orientada
hacia un pueblo llamado dao mail el dau
mail que conforma venir
y aquí las mujeres que van a recoger el
agua en la mañana y acompañan a la
princesa es el modelo insignia de la
colección que acompañan a la princesa en
la mañana a ir hacia el rey
y la última pieza que rebosa todo lo que
hay como tempestades dificultades
vestidas por el hombre que dice que el
hombre debe cuidar a la mujer y
viceversa esto es lo que vieron en el
evento esta noche la francesa kinder y
anthony inició su carrera como
influenciado ahora de moda y lanzó su
marca hace dos años en parís ciudad que
el abandono al principio de la pandemia
para refugiarse en lomé donde decidió
crear una moda internacional hecha en
áfrica kimberly anthony le apuesta a la
armonía de los géneros
entonces masculino femenino porque
corresponde a mi estilo de todos los
días estuve de hecho sigo estando un
poco en el estilo tom boys me gustan los
cortes amplios oversize me gusta
vestirme donde el hombre y donde la
mujer entonces trate de representar esto
en mi colección que ello haga cortes que
tanto el hombre como la mujer puedan
vestir así haya hecho piezas bastante
femeninas se quería que en general
hubiese esa distinción un poco
difuminada entre el hombre y la mujer
en cuanto a la togolesa cristela
noteboom ella lo cree a modas o
tendencias se inspira de ello para
componer sus canciones que interpreta
bajo el nombre de terciopelos negros su
lucha que separa de estigmatizar las
pieles oscuras en esta pandemia nos
permitió recordar de cierta forma lo que
es importante y creo que regresaremos
poco a poco a la protección de lo que
tenemos el planeta la cultura ponerla de
relieve de manera más visible tanto en
la moda como en otros ámbitos
entonces creo que es una buena
oportunidad y espero que la aprovechemos
como se debe con mi grupo a pesar de la
pandemia y sus efectos destructores en
la economía el octavo festival
internacional de la moda en todo logro
su apuesta conservar el compromiso de
sus padrinos y mecenas para hacer
emerger un nuevo escenario de diseño
africano